salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche et le
dimanche c'est le jour des explications
et je vais vous apprendre la technique
ultime pour faire disparaître un briquet
ce petit objet qu'on a tous pour allumer
des bougies d'anniversaire ou de
l'ensemble ou pour faire une jolie
flamme si vous avez un concert ou un
spectacle et où surtout vous regardez
cette vidéo dans les années 90 je vais
donc vous apprendre comment faire
disparaître ce petit objet et aussi
comment se servir de notre porte quel
objet comme d'un bric c'est un tour qui
peut se faire les manches commenté alors
vous remonter les manches et ensuite
vous faites disparaître complètement
le bric le seul problème c'est que
j'avais pas vérifié avant et ils
marchent pas ce qui est tout à fait
normal pour un rouleau de scotch c'est
très très rare qu'un rouleau de scotch
face du feu vous l'avez sûrement compris
à ce stade de la vidéo c'est un tour de
magie qui fonctionne en deux temps il ya
un détournement d'attention il ya une
illusion je vais être honnête avec vous
je me suis servi de cadre de la caméra
pour lâcher le briquet comme à main
commencé à sortir du champ vous aussi
vous pouvez faire exactement ça quand
vous êtes assis à une table en le
faisant tomber sur vos genoux et tout le
reste de l'illusion bien d'ailleurs un
lien de ce stylo qu'un stylo particulier
puisqu'il fabrique et met briquet qui
marchent pas et oui voilà c'est ça
toutes les visions du temps on vient du
fait de donner l'illusion d'avoir un
briquet de l'illusion sonore l'illusion
auditive je vous apprendre à part ça je
préfère vous prévenir vous allez avoir
la sensation d'avoir un super pouvoir et
vous allez vouloir tout transformer en
brie et vous aller coller votre langue
derrière vos dents supérieures cash à
celle qui a eu lieu au revers très
intelligent la langue est complètement
collés contre les dents et un petit peu
contre le palais et vous allez retirer
la langue très rapidement dans une
succession
ça donne l'illusion d'un bruit un petit
peu métallique il faut le faire le plus
rapidement possible quand je dis
rapidement ça veut pas dire terre très
rapidement ça veut surtout dire décoller
rapidement éviter de faire un bruit trop
lent il faut faire un bruit sec et
rapide
déjà ça fonctionne très très bien comme
ça mais si en plus vous placez votre
main comme si vous aviez un briquet et
d'autres mains comme pour protéger du
vent ça va créer une petite caisse de
résonance qui va amplifier l'illusion de
bruit métallique et avec ça tout peut se
transformer en brique et même un thé
dans les trucs très marrant à faire il
ya donc le fait de faire disparaître le
briquet de faire semblant de l'avoir et
de juste donner l'illusion du bruit
avant de le faire disparaître
vous pouvez aussi faire bugger le
cerveau des gens en prenant un briquet à
lambert en disant marche pas compliqué
pour le faire souvent je peux vous dire
que c'est très drôle parce que là vous
faites appel à la logique de la personne
vous avez le bric à l'envers ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est non
mal c'est logique mais en même temps il
sentira qu'il ya un bug il ya quelque
chose qui est pas normal et ce qui est
anormal c'est évidemment d'avoir entendu
le bruit du briquet alors qu'il était à
lambert je pense que vous allez vous
éclater tout l'autre dimanche et tout
votre semaine avec ça si le regardant
cette vidéo vous avez fait devant
l'écran tout en continuant de regarder
la vidéo vous pouvez me faire savoir en
mettant un pouce en l'air n'hésitez pas
à commenter d'ailleurs dans les
descriptifs il ya tous les réseaux
sociaux on peut se retrouver pensez à
vous abonner à la chaîne hier je vous ai
donné le nouveau défi est ce que
j'allais faire à l'issue de ce défi si
vous n'avez pas suivi regardez la vidéo
numéro 100 prenez soin de vous profitez
de ce dimanche et rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain modèle
fleuves chao